Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel at.
My name is Paul.
Today's topic is language death.
Normally on this channel,
when I talk about a language,
it's usually a living language,
a language that still spoken by native
speakers today and continues to grow and
evolve,
but there are also dead languages and
extinct languages.
Languages are considered dead when they
simply have no more native speakers,
even though they may continue to be used
in some way.
Latin is dead,
for example,
but it continues to be used for
religious purposes and for some
administrative purposes in the Vatican.
Some people can speak it but not
naturally like a native language and
it's not passed down as a native
language.
Another example is Hebrew,
which was a dead language before its
revival in the form of modern Hebrew.
Nobody spoke it natively for a long
time,
but it continued to be used for
religious purposes and as a written
literary language.
In contrast,
languages are considered extinct when no
living person can speak them.
For example,
if the last remaining speaker of a
native American language dies and nobody
has learned it as a second language than
that language becomes extinct.
Likewise,
ancient languages like Sumerian are
extinct.
Some people might be able to read
ancient texts in that language,
but nobody really uses it today.
Languages become either dead or extinct
as a result of language,
death types of language.
Death.
Languages don't always die in the same
way.
There are various types of language
death.
The most common way that languages
disappear is through gradual language
death.
This normally happens when speakers have
one language come into contact with a
language of higher prestige,
the language of a dominant more powerful
group of people.
That community may remain bilingual for
quite a long time,
but with each successive generation,
fewer young people speak their
traditional language and with lower
levels of proficiency as they opt to use
the prestige language instead until one
day their communities.
Traditional language is no longer
spoken.
An example of this as corniche,
which seems to be spoken by the late
19th century as a result of the growing
influence of English and also as a
result of the perception of Cornish as a
lower class language,
even amongst it's own speakers at the
time,
but cornish is actually not extinct
because there are revitalization efforts
to encourage people to continue to use
that language next bottom to top
language death in bottom to top language
death.
A language ceases to be used as a native
spoken language,
but continues to be used in certain
contexts.
Normally in a formal religious context
or ceremonial context or perhaps for
literary purposes.
In gradual language death,
the language normally disappears first
in more formal contexts as it's replaced
by the prestige language,
but it continues to be spoken in more
casual contexts for a longer time in
bottom to top language deaths.
On the other hand,
the language dies out at the bottom,
in other words,
in casual contexts,
but it continues to be used in more
formal contexts.
An example of this is Latin,
which is basically no longer used
outside of religious ceremonial contexts
or perhaps literary contexts.
Next,
southern language death.
Southern language death occurs when all
or almost all the speakers of a language
suddenly die as a result of a disaster
or violence.
An example of this took place in the 18
thirties in Tasmania when virtually all
of the islands native inhabitants were
wiped out by European colonists during
the black war.
Next,
radical language death similar to
southern language death,
radical language death normally happens
very rapidly and normally happens as a
result of political repression or under
threat of violence.
The difference is that the language has
speakers are not wiped out,
but suddenly stop using their own
language as a way to avoid persecution.
And example of this occurred in El
Salvador during an uprising in the 19
thirties when many aboriginals abruptly
stopped speaking their native languages
as a way to avoid being identified as
aboriginals and potentially killed two
languages that suddenly died out where
Linka and case studies.
Let's look at a few languages that have
already died and see if we could figure
out how they ceased to be spoken.
Old Church slavonic old church slavonic
is the first the tested Slavic language,
which was spoken and written between the
ninth and 11th centuries.
It was a standardized variety of Slavic
that was understood by speakers of the
various Slavic dialects of that time,
which were still quite similar to each
other,
those slavic dialects,
which were basically the colloquial form
of the same language,
gradually developed into the different
Slavic languages of today because it's
still used in some churches for
religious purposes today,
it's a liturgical language,
so it fits in with the category of
bottom to top language death.
The newly developing Slavic languages
replaced the old slavonic dialects as
the languages of daily life,
but old church slavonic continued to be
used for religious purposes and for a
certain amount of time for political
purposes.
It's worth noting that some dead
languages never actually died in both
the case of Latin and of old slavonic.
The language never stopped being spoken.
It just continued to evolve into
different languages.
Leaving the cotified literary language
behind as a separate dead language that
was no longer spoken,
the men then language in 2016,
a man named Edwin Benson,
the last remaining speaker of the men.
Then language passed away.
Men.
Dan was a native American language of
the Sewan language family,
which was spoken in the state of North
Dakota.
The population of men,
Dan speakers,
was nearly wiped out by an outbreak of
smallpox in the seventies and eighties
and again in the 18 thirties.
The cohesion of the remaining population
was limited by government relocation and
the construction of dams which separated
villages from each other.
While the influence of English group,
the fact that most of the population was
wiped out in tragic outbreaks of
smallpox would place this in the
category of southern language death.
Even though some speakers of the
language continued to live on among the
remaining speakers,
we can also say that there was an
element of gradual language death.
As more and more members of that
community began to speak the prestige
language English until one day,
men then was no longer spoken ghoulish
up until the sixth century seat.
A Celtic language called galesh was
spoken in what's now France when the
Romans conquered the area,
they made Latin the official language of
the state and being able to speak Latin
became a way to gain status and economic
opportunity for a number of centuries.
It was common to be bilingual and golish
vernacular and the prestige language
Latin until Latin finally replaced
golish entirely.
This is a clear case of gradual language
death as a population gradually gave up
their traditional language in favor of
the prestige language.
A joa between 19,
20 and 1940.
The agewell language died out in Nigeria
because it's entire community of
speakers switched to house up for
economic and practical reasons.
The entire community very rapidly
stopped using their traditional language
and it was not passed down to the next
generation.
This is an example of radical language
death when a language dies because all
of it speakers suddenly switched to
another language.
In many cases of radical language,
death,
the community gives up their language
for survival in the face of violence,
but in this particular case,
they gave up the agewell language
because it was more beneficial for their
community to speak Hausa.
Why should we care about language death?
Some people think that language death is
a good thing,
that less language diversity is a good
thing.
For example,
the leaders of some countries want one
language to be dominant and to replace
all of the others because they think
that will promote the unity of their
country.
On the other hand,
a language is part of a culture,
so when a language dies,
part of that culture dies and a unique
way of seeing the world dies with it.
For example,
let's look at the endangered color wire
language of Bolivia.
Columbia is used by a sect of medicine
men who learned the language not only to
understand the ritual practice and oral
tradition of their ancestors,
but also to understand the thousands
upon thousands of plant names specific
to the callaway or language that
explained the medicine will uses of
different plants in the local region.
If color disappears,
then all of that culture and secret
knowledge will disappear with it.
Linguistic diversity has been on a
steady decline and of the presence
nearly 7,000
languages on earth,
nearly half are endangered and the top
100 most spoken languages are spoken by
85 percent of the world's population.
Some endangered languages are finding
new life through revitalization efforts,
which require that the language first be
recorded and documented,
then learned by a new speakers and also
used by an enthusiastic and motivated
community and having some political
influence wouldn't hurt either.
The question of the day in your country
or in your region,
are there languages that are in danger
of dying or becoming extinct?
How would you feel about those languages
disappearing?
What's something important be lost?
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again,
thank you to all of my wonderful patrion
supporters,
especially my top tier patrion
supporters whose names are on the screen
right now.
Very many thanks to them.
By the way,
on the last video about Tokyo,
some of you asked why Toki Pona was
listed on the page of patrons and that's
because the creator of the Tokyo
[inaudible] language has been a patron
since last summer,
but preferred not to appear on the list,
but upon request,
I've begun listing the name of the
language instead.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.